avec nous la cavale la course folle du
Roi de l'Arnaque
Marco 14 pays j'aimerais il y a beaucoup
de jeunes qui nous regardent tu sais on
est l'émission la plus regardée par les
jeunes donc c'est vrai que il parlait
moins jeunes d'ailleurs voilà mais c'est
vrai que il y a plein de gens qui me
disent c'est vrai que Marco quand on
l'entend on se dit il a une vie
formidable il faut quand même que tu
rappelles que vraiment la prison voilà
il vaut mieux ne pas y aller la prison
bien sûr qu'il faut pas y aller il faut
pas se rattraper tu as le droit de voler
mais pas de faire rattraper non non non
non
un truc ne le fait pas parce que vous
faites attraper quoi qu'il arrive
aujourd'hui la justice attends la
justice elle a des moyens qui sont
énormes moi quand j'ai fait ma cavale
j'ai voulu faire un peu comme le film
attrape-moi si tu peux avec Léonardo
Dicaprio je suis en cavale je suis
j'étais à j'étais dans un bled à 4000 km
j'appelle une presse et je lui dis comme
il y a un flic qui m'a cassé un peu les
bonbons ils ont attrapé un ami à moi et
ils ont été de l'OTAN pour savoir dans
quel pays j'étais mais il a voulu rouler
le flic il a voulu et je sais qu'il
m'entend il a voulu frimer on va
l'attraper on va la voir bah vas-y je
l'ai appelé je lui ai dit mais dis-moi
qu'est-ce que tu veux chez moi toi fais
ton boulot de flic je lui dis mais tu es
même pas capable de m'attraper tu es
même pas de ton niveau j'ai Interpol sur
la gueule c'est pas toi tu es qui toi
ouais je vais t'attraper on va fêter le
champagne ah bah dis labada je suis
heureux écoute-moi bien on est quand
aujourd'hui dimanche mardi je suis à
Paris et devant ton commissariat
fais-moi si tu m'attrapes puis mardi
j'ai appelé la presse je me suis fait
prendre en photo avec Vincent meunier
l'Obs et là j'ai donné la preuve que de
la cavale j'ai quand même été en France
et je suis quand même parti donc voilà
c'est pour faire montrer qu'en réalité
ne volez pas et tout ça je rigole mais
tout est possible dans la vie même de
travailler de gagner de l'argent sans
voler bien entendu s'envoler c'est le
mais c'est possible bien sûr que c'est
possible
de toute façon mieux que toi pour le
faire montrer
non mais tu es un exemple moi je t'ai
connu quand tu étais raide aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
ta force comment tu tapes tous les jours
tous les jours c'est pour ça que je te
défonce c'est parce que j'aime ton
courage j'aime tu vas être toujours le
numéro 1 bah moi aussi je veux être
toujours le numéro dans tout ce que je
fais une cabane une escroquerie du
travail je veux être le numéro 1 je
parle je vois pas que je fais de la
méchanceté je vois pas que je fais mal
je vais être le meilleur voilà et puis
après il y en a qui aiment qui en a qui
aiment pas moi ça va j'ai payé ma dette
personne peut m'en vouloir je suis en
train de casquer les impôts je suis en
train de casquer de ma vie qui a été
foutu pendant 7 ans parce que parce que
une vie en prison quand tu fais un an ça
va ça va ah non ça va tu fais tu frimes
j’étais en placard ouais tu pars accès
mais sept ans de ta vie que tu te lèves
le matin il s'est toujours la même chose
et tu crois que tu vas prendre des
droites dans ta gueule tu as peur de
descendre en promenade et si tu es sympa
en promenade il te dit celui-là il fait
un trouillard il descend pas en
promenade tu te rends compte que dans ta
tête tu te dis bon allez je vais en
prendre date et je vais prendre une
Talais malade
j'y vais moi de dire ça j'ai été chez
dit comme ça je me prends pour un homme
mais il faut être un homme dans tout ça
veut dire qu'il faut savoir se faire
frapper il faut savoir frapper il faut
savoir gagner il faut savoir perdre et
pour gagner il faut savoir perdre et ça
c'est toute la vie il faut pas pleurer
quand tu perds parce qu'il y a des
moments où tu gagnes il y a la forme et
il y a des moments c'est comme le poker
le poker quand tu perds ne va pas
chercher mais quand tu gagnes la forme
elle arrive
quand je garde moi mais quand je sais
que quand je suis en forme je peux te
dire qu'il y a plus une thune partout
mais parce que je vais être le numéro
aussi là-dedans moi je pense que pour
aider les jeunes
aller travailler même si vous gagnez
1000 euros vous lever le matin déjà vous
sentez bien et puis après le parcours il
va grandir après tu sais moi j'ai fait
les marchés
j'étais chez le patron le patron 5h du
matin il faisait froid et il me disait
de lave les pommes j'étais dans l'eau je
l'avais les pommes j'ai dit quelle
chance je le regardais comme ça je
regardais comme je savais pas comment
j'étais payé il me dit à la fin de la
semaine tu auras cinq balles 5 francs
c'est ok je vais t'avoir je vais te
voler dans la caisse pas de ma faute
et t'as pas compris
désolé moi je me venge
alors toi je m'occupais que de toi
aujourd'hui non mais je te le dis parce
que toi on dirait un premier de la
classe mettez loin de là c'est loin de
là parce qu'ils connaissent pas ta vie
tu as compris moi je veux les gens je
veux aujourd'hui qu'on connaisse ta vie
je veux le dire je me mets que sur ta
tête aujourd'hui que sur ta tête et j'ai
rien dit le seul problème que j'ai dans
dans ce que tu as dit et ça c'est ça
rien à voir c'est vrai que moi j'en
parle encore tout à l'heure le problème
qu'on a aujourd'hui en France et
ailleurs c'est qu'il y a des gens qui se
réveille tous les jours à 8h du matin
qui terminent à 19h et malheureusement
il travaille toute la journée ils n'ont
même pas pour pour
pas travailler 5 jours sur 7 ou 6 jours
sur 7 et se dire et je peux pas je sais
pas ce que je vais manger le soir alors
que j'ai travaillé toute la journée ça
c'est pas possible mais c'est affreux
donc alors quand tu dis ça s'il te plaît
Cyril comprends-moi qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait non mais justement ouais mais tu
peux pas tu peux pas dire parce que non
mais quand je peux pas dire ça ça veut
dire quand tu vois ta famille dans la
souffrance quand tu vois qu'on est dans
un studio il y a 7 frères et sœurs qui
mangent et qui dort tu te rends compte
que chez moi chez ma mère les toilettes
tu avais même pas besoin de te lever je
faisais ça seulement
tu te rends compte quand tu vis avec des
frères et sœurs il y a pas d'ozère
et puis tu vois sortir
avec ta mère elle est chauffeur de taxi
la nuit elle est elle est continuer à
l'école la journée le matin elle se lève
à 4h du matin pour nous faire à manger
et chaque fois je disais à ma mère
qu'est-ce qu'il y a à manger aujourd'hui
elle me disait du des gâteaux je te
rappelle des petits bras c'était les
gâteaux les moins chers
pas si j'en ai marre je vais te répondre
je vais te répondre te prends pas la
tête tu veux te répondre il va te
répondre
c'est la vérité que si tout le monde a
été commis mais à quoi ça sert de
descendre dans la rue et demander de
dire j'ai faim à quoi ça sert qu'est-ce
que vous avez gagné quand vous êtes des
les lois ils sont tous passés non mais
non non
ils ont fait bouger les choses mais ils
ont fait bouger les résultats il va plus
avoir d'électricité le résultat c'est
que oui le résultat c'est qu'on a parlé
c'est autre chose événements qui ont
fait désolé
tous les week-ends
beaucoup de problèmes bien sûr mais
pourquoi on va se mêler les autres pays
pourquoi tu veux te battre contre la
Russie contre Musclor mais c'est comme
en prison tu peux pas te battre contre
un mur à la fin c'est un problème mais
non j'ai le même problème aujourd'hui
c'est mon combat
[Musique]
elle est en train de faire tu sais que
ça veut dire le bluff le bleu
c'est pas du bleu on verra bien tu
verras que tout va s'arranger non
écoute-moi
alors s'il existe tout va s'arranger
parce qu'il laisse l'être humain
tranquille alors j'aimerais qu'on sur
ton émission dans un instant sur
l'émission que tu as fait samedi soir
avec Léa salam et Christophe Dechavanne
qui a une séquence qui a été coupée
juste avant Jean-Michel qui connaît bien
aussi non parce que je comprends très
bien que des gens critiquent Marco parce
qu'ils disent on peut pas encenser
quelqu'un qui a arnaqué l'État comme ça
mais le fait est là c'est quand vous
sortez avec Marco et cetera il ne fera
pas de cavale parce que maintenant
aujourd'hui ou marcher avec eux dans la
rue vous êtes au restaurant il y a pas
il se passe pas 3 minutes donc quelqu'un
vienne lui demander de photos fasse une
vidéo
embouteillages dans la rue et toutes les
le nombre de femmes qui viennent le voir
en lui disant
ça tu peux pas me l'enlever il est
habillé comme un prince Harry majeur à
chaque fois que je te croise au
restaurant je dis qui est ce sourire à
valeur
Marco et il est magnifique ouf qui vient
de dire est très important oui je suis
aimé c'est ça c'est tout le livre c'est
ça on voit que c'est un homme prêt à
tout pour être aimé et pour sa famille
non mais je vais te raconter une
anecdote je sais que c'est fait pour
nous oui j'étais à Cannes j'étais jeté
parce que l'immobilier là-bas est
beaucoup plus beau côté à la bulle
beaucoup plus de rentabilité qu'à Paris
c'est pour ça que je suis là-bas en ce
moment parce que il va y avoir des
problèmes donc je vais être là tu sais
que tu gagnes de l'argent au moment de
guerre et non pas et parce que il y en a
on commence la guerre donc on gagne on
gagne pas l'argent il y a la guerre
après faut reconstruire donc moi je suis
là pour un peu reconstruire si tu veux
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça qu'on
gagne de l'argent et je vais à Cannes et
puis d'un seul coup tu connais
l'histoire des tu prends les pierres tu
les jettes dans l'eau j'arrive mais pour
de vrai
je prends les pierres pour les jeter bon
c'était comme toi je comprends pas tout
le monde avec l'appareil photo en train
de me faire des photos je dis c'est
comme top je comprends pas même là et
puis je jette mes pierres et puis je
fais des prières tu vois je fais pierre
[ __ ] il y a un mec qui me dit tiens
j'en ai encore quatre pour toi
je sais pas si il me charrie et je vois
une vieille personne de enfin une
vieille personne 75 80 à peu près mais
stylé le mec et il me dit tu as pas
honte
je suis d'accord j'ai honte de quoi
dis-moi de quoi j'ai honte mais tape pas
honte la communauté qu'est-ce que tu as
fait qu'est-ce que tu as pas fait
et je lui ai dit tu sais dans la Bible
dans la Torah tu sais qu'est-ce qui a
marqué il y a marqué de vivre on vit
dans une vie matérielle il faut être
riche et ben j'ai suivi la Bible à toi
voilà et pour être riche
[Rires]